oh the poker scene and actually you can
serve as the model go ahead sit down
there I have a model now games I'm a
camera model okay and the tricky part is
that we have to make it we have to make
it pretty dark
Moses you know the art stuff I mean we
can tape up like all the other things
and everything but we need if you can
see this though yeah it's the only
really dark room we have but those
material is kind of sparkly and glittery
and stuff like that it's to stop the
sound from spreading so um we had to
make a really really dark because of it
I think this will work out okay that's
what you look like
whoa whoa have you ception proud
probably take the good go first I gonna
watch you laugh okay cuz our skin tones
are much different just just a little
bit
oh I'm just doing a survey on your
coping here
oh how many spaces do you guys have are
you guys bolt we are here the other nice
thing about having is really dark is
that the director I'm doing read is
supposed to be completely bald and in
the dark I think I didn't look
completely bare back in everything uh
whose character is that okay these are
all records in these films that like
anyone would swear would Bob you know
like the recipe
Oh someone wants to get it out of it but
she's obviously no good at but he's
still best he can do it he can make a
good movie even as a bad plot it's
ridiculous
so I get incredibly old lame poker chips
those are but all they should look good
on camera though because they're very
very bright colored by me they're like
super and white I think anyone would
play with them for real I do too
these are actually these are my
grandmother's actually because you add a
line something Walker is no middle did
some heirlooms for you career then now
the real question is this pride doesn't
matter at all for filming but I ask
myself now should they do you know
whether everyone's still playing you
know Texas Hold'em and stuff but film
wise it looks so much cooler if they're
all just holding up like you know the
five cogs like that right so maybe
they're playing that I'm not sure yet
they're playing something with chips
yes go ahead
yeah you got the duck
at the time no no we say that's 2006 and
they like make up that I think it's an
or they make a bet for her to do frozen
then she makes a bet I think okay just
want to maintain yeah ant-man and then
lego movie so it's all and then Sean
long gets in you know like you know hey
let's you know I wanted us to so yeah
he'd you know what these guys look like
yeah I look them up okay I mean they're
not they don't look exactly like us but
you know I watch a sort of a vague idea
you know and we say they are and stuff
like that so yeah I haven't looked up
what they sound like or anything so one
day's like a high-pitched voice I have
no idea so yeah so I mean we're just
gonna play just like you know we're cool
kids and a poker party pretty much was
it yeah go ahead only time ever go ahead
and get um get the suit coat on and
we'll see how you look in the way we're
gonna shoot the scene we are we are
children of the 70s and 80s put together
okay ladies Miller which is played by
Robbie
you just got to a time Oh Jim we're
going to give you very few chips Rob
you're gonna act like you're taking like
a lot of chips like a you just want out
yeah no you have no idea how to play
poker
do you know how to play poker it's
winning it like two chips give her
something Oh give yourself up
yeah just for whatever reason you're
really really smokin okay so all right
so read which is me I am over here
Shyamalan is going to be here and then
tan chairs Chandler was that tan chair
yes the are you doing great Jim who's
Malcolm plain Oh sham Berlin that's true
yeah I was voicing him oh I miss the
dicker told me called Susan oh I'm Leah
on the focus by the way Jim I know how
this our balconies just please do
business - final war it is all your
chips not think actually in a poker game
what a twist
what did tweet with a clue shit yes now
turn off the man manual focus shit oh I
see you got it perfect okay all right
cool um so what this is like I said
we're gonna do kind of all your guys oh
this is my hand is first period pretty
okay hey remember also I'm Miller yeah
you're Miller Jim is Lord um Jim Jim is
Lord dressed like that
oh yeah so Rob as soon as I say yeah
you're gonna be bringing the chips
towards you I'll say and I'll probably
just cue you because I don't want to go
over the rambling and the chips so thank
are the line I'm guessing well done
Chris Miller well done I'll just point
you to say you know thank you you know
and I'm over here so so so you're saying
thank you too and then Jim you have this
lovely long line okay it's assistant but
hey he's not the only one we should
congratulate I hear our own Jennifer Lee
got a job writing and directing at
Disney yeah and she's exactly where she
is so gets good spot you better smile go
mmm
thank you
but he's not the only one who should
congratulate our own Jennifer Lee has
gotten a job writing and directing at
Disney oh it's nothing just the most
famous studio in the world never have
your line is
well I suppose now we can bring her in
on our real Kendall well I suppose now
we can bring her in on our real gamble
what gamble Oh every time a new
filmmaker comes along we make an
impossible dare to see if they're good
enough to pull it off
really and Jimmy why is yes and they in
turn make deers bed yes and they in turn
make dares back uh touch louder and be a
little bit more you know intrigue like
we shall play a game I guess give me
give me one side let's play with the one
yesterday go okay
live your agent okay yes and they in
turn make dares back no I liked a
resurrection look it Jimmy's dears back
it's a tasty kitten yeah look in another
strip no I like just the lucky just I
mean the edge o champion oh you want me
to leave yeah we could share yeah okay
ready and action
yes and they in turn think there's
nobody touch this chicken seeing how
you're the newcomer and with Disney I
bet you can't make a film that points
out all the fault of the past Disney
films has two female leads one of them a
queen and yeah
I you two are just gonna go alright
alright yeah three this what a pop isn't
enough
ready 1 2 3
there you 1 2 3
why are we eating things any last time I
wasn't no I was with Annabelle it what
and have her sing a song so popular even
boys will be singing it and that's what
you're gonna do it again but just do
like twos like cuts back to me has chips
rocks I don't know if it'll I don't
think it's anybody's you did the first
year with us spit out okay I could never
actually swallowed it alright ready 1 2
let me let me do this bit take right
don't choke on it
yeah alright AB 1 2 3
you don't do one more mouth acting this
is very Catholic ha ha ha okay hey 1 2 3
stupid so Tamra Cena say okay I like a
challenge especially in this demographic
ruled by thirteen-year-old boys around
again say they're always the most
popular as I say it to Jim like you know
they're always we have like fakes so I
like a better skip always the more
popular thank you yeah I'll be there
just yeah I'll do that
no it start out doing they're always the
most popular I'll be the whole minute
they're always the most popular doesn't
matter this profitable or populist uh-oh
positive oh yes thank you good catch
okay okay ready yep and actually they're
always the most profitable business okay
we'll do one more yeah
is it where can you see it fast hey easy
there
fine yeah okay ready yeah and action
they're always the most profitable I
like the little noise it makes it's like
burning up
smooth it there's another security
gorillas actually baby they're not yeah
just I'm getting this all the girls go
watch it what stop doing all they think
is very good
all right well I'm good if I achieve
that you have to make a successful
superhero movie about a man who's the
size of an ant yeah
no I are we staring at each other or be
scaring it carefully
III think Voyager yeah seems to be the
trend so you just always turn and then
uh well here try wrapping your glasses
now we'll just do a run-through of page
two um yeah so it's gonna be um you know
shrinking films are box-office poison
now and one two three good uh Jim I say
uh take your hands off the table
probably yeah III think that's what's
doing it anyway okay ready yeah and one
two three
great um let's see
you know shrinking films are box-office
poison now what's the matter not
accepting my raise and I'll give you
guys the cue on that this is the Jeff
balloon just like more like a monocle
just one happy yeah five are you making
fun of me over here so that's what your
point you good hey ready and one two
three oh oh sorry Omar hey ready yep and
one two three
Oh Ronna okay
Oh was it lean to the lion here hey
we're just as ballsy is either of you
okay bills are plentiful ya feelin yeah
hey okay okay ready yeah yeah oh I'll
call not the Miller and Lord over there
have the balls to okay we're just as
balls use either you yeah prove it
I wasn't rude
hi oh you did yeah yeah this is gonna be
the big reline okay so it's we're just
as balls easy
prove it dumps it in again you have your
line and that fact people be upset that
wasn't your best picture
okay that's a me Picture Best Animated
picture am i talking to both of you I
mean mainly me but if you want to hurt
her once or twice as fun and hey Robbie
as soon as I say no no oh yeah okay
ready and hey mind if I play one two
three
no no no no no no no no no no no oh
absolutely
okay I'll do know one okay ready and hey
mind if I play one two three
no nope double note and new
let's see here I would rather die in a
fire the one thing you'll get from this
angle as I won't get a shot from of you
okay put all the chips in the middle
there yeah Ollie oh I just opened up a
royal flush haha oh except for a ten
dammit so cool
oh so it's not a real flashy tactic
worthless and you would have had it been
dealing anyway so it wouldn't make any
difference
yeah Rob does not apply I said I know
what a point yeah I just don't know how
to win it
oh wait no this what you have to take
everywhere saying the other night okay
now see jinkies I always wanted to play
though man tom is the best Stephanie's
just a bimbo true that it's justice it
almost secretly had you feel like you
could get the vellum Oh somehow did
definitely top a chance with Devon and
just to say I do wonder what lego movie
would have been like if shamil's right
they're all Lincoln launched actually no
knowing shaman since there's a twist
already the twist would be there is no
twist they're just all really Legos and
there's no outside world
just just Legos just like and it would
be boring and Will Smith would be in it
the end his son you know he was doing a
bit all in the child's mind or something
in aliens was head boy oh oh yeah why
are you throwing the aliens Israel it
turns out the Legos are girls
yeah they're ghosts all right they don't
even realize if you can um
don't put your hands too much on the
table like hitting it or anything like
that but you can keep them on the table
because it does add a little bit to the
yeah there you go Jim build a crane so
we can Jen that have to set on a fish it
may be awesome um we do yeah I was just
about to say we could use it but I oh oh
yeah
all right can you welcome that's gonna
be rough thank you oh I feel like the
only one like david bohm Angele
I'm your own really just watching me
you're right making fun of it
right after he does world Doug thinks
this is timely I'm not so sure we'll see
what happens I knew we will do it with
lawful flux we did Jurassic Park at home
and I actually like enjoy those movies
so yes
Jurassic Park movies are the most times
ever seven times in the cinema so I
figure if I could do that I can do
laughs okay yeah which I have seen 70
times a home video oh my goodness that's
more like an homage ask antic don't
always it was profitable I feel I feel
like this is a mob scene like there's
some informant in the corner chained to
a radiator I wanted to feel very god I
always wanted you to seem like this just
with one overhead line with a darkly
background well that's why I'm curious
if we can get out of it
but but yeah that's a nice thing you
just Flav the Contras be like it was
intentional it's supposed to looking at
darker
I wish we should have brought the fog
machine we could have made it all smoky
by it look like we'd be playing in tails
on the crisp yeah I just wish there were
a lot of dogs also playing poker with us
a lot of dogs there to us play poker
oh no homie that one's okay yes I mean
Reid is here and Lord and know we're
there yeah just hey and then you turn it
over here mind if I play and I'll go 1 2
3 you just go it up no no no no no no he
just like a yeah just anyway to say no
over and over no no no no noises oh yeah
what why not you are terrible at this
game shambles Shama Shama Shama stare
shaken stirred good I did those are
pretty short so we should be able to
sham Alon yeah the sham stir that's what
I refer to him as he has a twist all
along potentially being bad head he know
that it wasn't good to begin a yes oh
damn
you know shrinking films are box-office
poison right now what's the matter
not taking my raise oh I'll take your
raise at the Miller Lord over there I
have the balls to hey Nova ballsy's
either of you prove it I bet we can do a
product placement will be so good that
we name the movie after the product that
nobody would care in fact people will be
so upset that was even nominated for
Best Animated picture hey that's it do
the again maybe like just our work
elsewhere so you can have more of a
drastic turn yeah okay don't look
straight at him yeah all right
ready and action hey mind if I play one
two three no no no no no just be saved
me one that's like you know well okay
tell her everything's you know assistant
grab a set and one two three no no no no
no no no no no nope nope nope nope nope
no no no no uh one more just start off
with the waving the hands up no no no
then whatever else you want you onto
that that's I just be sure you say no
all right ready 1 2 3
no no no no no no no no no smiling I
just like oh no like keep that shit away
from me ready and one two three
no no nope nope no no no no nope nope
nope nope no no no no no no no no no no
it's a group of people you're fighting
together alien has a movie for a little
kid I think is way fucking scary yeah oh
yeah by the end it's just it's just her
you don't even yeah for you know new
this really just Herbers the hunted
can't sanity it's like you're kidding
yeah yeah it is I was terrified of alien
it when I was little I couldn't watch it
by myself yeah I saw Terminator Intel
when I was seven and like that scared
fuck yeah
the first thing was yeah the first one
the funny thing is it wasn't everything
else it was simply the two things that
scare me one when he started talking
about those are you still Connor and
blows people's brains out because that
was always like a kid's worst nightmare
you open the door and so he's got a gun
yeah and the other thing that scared me
none of the all the bloodshed it was at
the very end when he it's the skins
burned off and he's just a robot
skeleton
yeah that's everybody's e effect now but
as a kid well that's what I get can't be
killed terrified me and I'm like you
can't and you can't reason with this
thing either cuz it's a machine so yeah
that scared me as a child but you know
what I fucking live yeah I got so don't
rate things pg-13 let it be rated R and
like kids stick it on the side like we
add back of the glass yes a very fine
yeah there's the same in my house though
my daddy yeah yeah it's like a dead boy
kids don't yeah my dad's like hey let's
watch Elia yeah sure my my dad took my
brother and I we were very young my
brother was super young see cast away
which was pg-13 and that it's not like
anything crazy maybe it all but but my
mom found out she was so bad at my dad
pretenders pg-13 yeah sure think it's
got Tom Hanks in yeah he's no stars of
beach ball it was just like there was
nothing like crazy about it but she was
so bad my mom flipped out when we got to
see Naked Gun two-and-a-half oh really
my dad kept honest I don't get half the
jail you go up to
we always yeah like I look at middle
schoolers nowadays and I'm just like oh
I'm like yeah that's right we pretty
much knew all this shit by middle school
but I have the same problem I'm like
really like your expose I'm like I guess
I was why would they be so big and like
protecting children's fragile little
minds is he I think your Dean's way
worse because it just teaches kids oh
well these bold people way mindlessly no
responsibility it's like to me the whole
I find the whole thing of like oh well
we're gonna totally errata sizes chick
but you never see any nudity weirder
right yeah absolutely
just yes even more bizarre creepier it
is it absolutely because it seems more
insidious that way well it's just like
because then you're just aiming it at
kids then like you're not even
pretending like it's like if listen we
all would yeah we were trying to watch
Showtime and see the beat
we're all signing up for three traps I
can almost get it in dad like didn't
hide the playboys around and it's just
like yeah we survive like we're in
normal relationships right how I assumed
in on you is he said that
right yeah it's like we survived so it's
like gone now now everything has to be
pg-13 it's like I don't find it yeah
censorship is movie said like the
r-rated movies affected me more and I'm
like oh this is I had I knew that this
was hardcore like this was violent is
shit
this was different you felt like an
adult watching it I think if you remove
that aspect of it it just makes a nice
yeah yeah I totally agree that's very
true
well the whole Deadpool thing it's like
oh so you can take him to see a pg-13
Deadpool is your kid gonna be any better
for seeing a pg-13 death I'm not talking
about Citizen Kane here it's fucking
dead it's dead you're not gonna be
smarter for seeing in the matter what so
even we need to mess this up or we need
to add something out like what do you
think she's gonna be library Oh maybe
like a like a hat like a baseball hat or
something like that that might be
supposed wrong right yeah I feel like
something in it though like yeah oh it's
like stop it Roly Ya Roly ah but not I'm
not a hole but you need just like three
or four rollers basically little pink
leaves here you want this one Yeah right
is it like yeah rub your cheek Louie
there you go
we are saying like we're gonna have her
in this outfit with waddles and just be
like you know next review that gets good
his gravity falls really is like nope
yes holy really I would not be there
cruel to our fans I would have done
something even more difference be with
everyone a fan did I give us this but
literally but we have another one up
there that was hand knit for we have
like - whoa yeah yeah there's hand this
for Rob and literally Tara goes
oh my god we they're exactly like that
right it was like oh yeah it was longer
so we said well the bevels handed those
to Robyn's tough butter fan got us this
one so we just assume those channel
awesome in spirit so we are giving it Oh
gifts from fans
I'm keeping the knit one I keep them
both but sharing is caring
Oh get up she hasn't even seen the
goddamn show oh no see that okay that's
the price you have to pay you have to
see the show okay so salmon there's um
says I don't get old I love love um I
made a post on my face Sam oh yeah hey
Sam can do the moose right get a candy
in my mouth oh yeah yeah hey Sam come
closer
well done but I posted this on my
Facebook I said whoever gets me this for
Christmas will make my holiday I was
joking of course
but someone actually got it goes my
Charlie but do you mind
so yeah I'm very happy it's literally a
sweater dress again it's very on has
only she can find me sense it's like
uncovering something out of the lawsuits
it's very maybe I bought this for my a
good Christmas sweater party but I have
worn it in the house many times since
you look like a toddler wearing mommy's
shirt yeah yeah that is what it is Jess
yeah it's either one you think dear with
two heads
that's when tree twigs or like that
they're two little deer having sex I
like that theory too yeah
it's both they're both yeah it mutant
alien deer who are having some it's a
mutant deer you're having sex that's for
the mutation they are always having sex
aren't your parents proud my mom bought
this for me I was just say this your mom
know that you stole a shirt gave it to
her what how well we're doing like the
shooting of the oranges with the with
the happening like it you especially
we're just so excited to do anything
with Malcolm and the origin it's just no
I want to make it I want to make it an
actual superhero
yeah just with the oranges in the eyes
like cuz he shoots the ladies it's like
I really want me yeah woo her work one
to me it was a blaxploitation um
superhero movie called Orange Julius
remember it was black just the new
orange yeah boy orange a no that was a
tagline orange is the new black and is
what the name of the character was video
1 oh yeah but the name of the character
was Orange Julius yeah tangerine
yeah you know you mean hot love at
injury yes tangerine juice every next
one at i/o oh crap if we get some Asian
girl can we call her Mandarin oh the man
you know what we gotta bring Brad into
this don't feel just feel like um bread
you know we tell Briggs no literally we
call Brad up now and be like oh shit
I'll be right there and then five
seconds later he'll just like pull off
he's like I really shoot this fucker
ideas like I'm outside
I knew you you were coming up with this
idea right well exploitation films
starring a guy with oranges for eyes I'm
in ok
possibly c-note can I drink an Orange
Julius while directing this thing laughs
what's got the Dreamsicle team yeah
you're you're totally onboard right we
have to make this happen